yes it's the eight news now symphony
orchestra we're talking about
the las vegas strip this is a map of the
northern part of the strip you've got
the venetian there heras
caesar's palace over there and this blue
dot well that's the mirage which is now
officially back
in business the iconic resort one of the
final las vegas strip properties to
reopen from those coronavirus shutdowns
and visitors are noticing some familiar
changes that have been forced by the
pandemic
we have hector mejia live at the mirage
right now right on the casino floor
hector good afternoon to you
hey there the mirage was closed for six
long months we've been talking to people
right next door from california others
from canada who came out here
just to see the las vegas strip slowly
come back to life so right now
we are here at the check-in area the
front lobby where you can see the front
desk here
we have plexi glass that is the new way
to check in and off
right at the end of the room here that's
a section for
contactless check-in we were talking to
the ceo
and president here at the mirage who was
telling us that he hopes guests have
more of an
intimate experience here kind of like a
boutique hotel
so let's take you back a couple of hours
ago when they reopened their doors after
being closed for six months
that happened around 10 o'clock this
morning we had hotel executives
employees
they all welcomed a steady stream of
deaths there were claps and cheers
that officially ended a nearly six-month
closure caused by this pandemic
the hotel's capacity is gradually
reopening depending on demand
that means more locals who depend so
much on tourism
are returning to work this is an
extremely emotional day for
for me as i walked through the hotel i
cried
a little bit didn't want the guests to
see that but maybe they did the same as
they walked through
the mirage is home to many of our guests
our guests love it this is my home for
21 years
so i am so happy to be returning here
today we came out here to go to the
secret garden i like the dolphins
because they do a lot of really cool
tricks
and there's also that really cool
underground area it's a big thing
for this hotel to be closed almost six
months and then be reopened it's just
like
giving excitement back to all the people
you know that
love vegas
the woman you just heard from is a
blogger from canada and a huge golden
knights van she came out here just to
see the new norm
which now includes among other things
hand sanitizing stations barriers social
distancing
looking back when the mirage first
opened back in 1989 it ushered in a new
era of mega resorts on the strip
and i can tell you it already smells
like sunscreen out here the pool is open
so are some restaurants and also
the dolphin habitat those are reopening
today
the only two other properties left to
reopen under the mgm resorts umbrella
are park mgm and four seasons reporting
from the mirage hector mejia
8 news now